he's blocking it out right right so back
to to the first class when i met
um i played i played a gig and i'd gone
to this
all-night uh truck stop restaurant
and uh 24 hours and i was like two
o'clock in the
1 32 o'clock in the morning as i pulled
my car into the parking lot
this guy was sitting on top of this
woman she was
lying on her back he was straddled
across her
and he was banging her head into the
sidewalk and punching her in the face
and there were several other guys
standing there watching
watching not doing anything but watching
right
and i'm pulling it apart i'm seeing this
i'm like what the hell
i got out of my car and when i slammed
my door
it got the guy's attention he like looks
up you know i had no idea who he was
what he was anything like that
and um i'm looking at him i'm going to
walk over there he goes
what you want a piece of meat [ __ ]
well that was to me that was open
invitation
oh my god i said yeah so he got up and
he came at me and i
i beat the crap out of him i beat him up
pretty bad
now how do you know he's a klansman i
didn't i didn't know i didn't know that
at the time but it wouldn't matter to me
anyway right
okay so then these idiots
that are standing around watching him
beat up this woman then they go and call
the police
they don't call the police when he's
beating up some lady but then when some
black guy beats the crap out of him
they go call the police right so these
two cops show up
and um they're talking to him
and something was very strange i could
not put my finger on it at the time
but something just did not add up right
and i wanted him arrested
now i didn't get hurt he got hurt and i
wanted him arrested but um
they would not arrest him they told him
to vacate the premises
and if he came back within 24 hours they
would have to arrest him for trespassing
right so i made sure that i got his
information
from the police they had to give it to
me before before they let him go
right so i got his information and i
went inside the restaurant i got some
ice
held to this lady's head took care of
her i said listen
you know if you want me to go to court
with you i'll be happy to go to court
with you she said okay and she said
you know she would testify on my behalf
as well then you know he'd attacked me
or whatever
said okay so we exchanged phone numbers
all right so then
um it turns out she was his ex-fiance
and she had dumped him because he was
seeing somebody else he'd gotten some of
the girl pregnant or whatever
and so he was upset because he still
wanted hurry as well
he wanted his cake and eat it too so it
was like if i can't have you nobody will
bam bam bam bam bam that kind of thing
god damn it okay yeah
so um he left the premises right
i'm taking care of her head and then i
said you know what i'm i'm i'm going to
go down
since these cops would not arrest him
i'm going to go swear out a uh a warrant
for him
and um and a complaint so
i said you're okay you know you're gonna
be okay she said yeah so i left
i went down to the police station and
i'm filling out this uh complaint to
have him arrested
a warrant i'm sitting there with the
commissioner
um i'm just about finished and um
i said how long well how long before
this guy would be served he said oh
probably about three days
you know i'll sign off on it he'll send
it down to the sheriff's
department and then one of the deputies
will serve him probably two or three
days
it's okay and then right about then in
walks the guy that i beat up
and walks him in handcuffs he's cuffed
behind his back
this time when the cops first came
it was two frederick county cops all
right
this time it's two maryland state
troopers
they don't play the troopers do not play
county cops
they play okay okay so troopers don't
don't play you mess up
they got you so anyway they got this guy
and and i i i see him through the big
you know picture glass window
that's him right there that's him right
there and the guy says sign it i'll
serve him right now
so i signed it commissioner rolled it up
walks out
and takes it and sticks it in between
his arms his arm is cuffed behind his
back
says you know you've been served so it
turns out long story short
that's hilarious man after the the
county cops left
he came back looking for me because he
figures i'm in the restaurant eating
right and he's going to settle the score
i beat him up so he's only
he came back to to finish up and um he
couldn't find me
he picked a fight with some other black
guy in the uh in the restaurant
so this time the maryland state troopers
came
i guess you know they were closer by
than the county cops and
um they arrested him wow and brought him
in right so then
um long story short
uh the day came for the year for the
hearing
and um i go pick up his uh his ex-fiance
and we go to court together in my car
and on the way there she tells me
that uh he's a klansman and um and that
he uh
is a fireman a frederick county fireman
and that explained the whole thing to me
because that's why the cops let them go
you know county cops know county firemen
you know they they appear on the same
scenes
right you know so they know each other
and so you know they
they you know let them go
but but with the maryland state police
the troopers you know they don't know
him
so they so i could say you know they
don't play so anyway
um he was a fireman and um
i show up there in the court with her
and when he saw me walk in with his
ex-fiancee
man he turned all kinds turns red of
that curtain over there
and his new fiance was there too right
she's
she's she's sitting on the bench
pregnant and she had a sweater and she
had taken off
and rolled it up and set it next to her
on the bench so now we're sitting on the
other side there on this side
and we're you know a few more cases get
called and then our case gets called
and then um so we all go up front and so
his defense attorney um tells the judge
that he was celebrating that night
he had been promoted from sergeant to
lieutenant
in the county fire department and so he
had a little too much to drink
and he mouthed off and um and got into
an altercation
with mr davis the plaintiff um
he the attorney said nothing about him
banging this woman's head into the
sidewalk
all he friended was as just some little
you know
tussle right in the parking lot and so
i'm saying that so you know man you know
you've missed out the story
so i didn't say that and in my turn to
testify
i said exactly what happened well
the new fiancee did not realize he was
still
seeing or trying to see the old fiance
she wanted nothing to do with him the
the
the old one right this new one got
pissed
now he's standing up front facing the
judge at the
at the defense table she's sitting
behind in one of the
benches she took her sweater and
threw it and hit him in the back and
walked out of the courtroom
right so after i told her told the judge
you know what what i what i saw was
going on when i pulled in the parking
lot
and then what i subsequently found out
so
he's all beat red again because now you
know he
you know he's lost his new fiance he
lost that one
and and and his and now a new side of
the story is coming out
so the judge found him guilty and uh
sentenced him
to like a weekend in jail and some
trivial sentence
and he had to do you know like 200 hours
community service
something like that but uh you know that
was the first
first cleanse when i i encountered [ __ ]
i mean i didn't know he was close at the
time but again
it wouldn't matter to me
foreign